This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Philip Zimbardo grew up poor. I was born in New York City in the South Bronx. And as he went to school and played in his neighborhood, he noticed something. There were lots of ways for kids from poor families to get into trouble. One of the things about growing up poor is you're surrounded by evil, meaning people whose job it is to get good kids to do bad things for money. And even as a little kid, I was always curious about why some kids got
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。菲利普·津巴多出身贫寒。我出生在纽约市的南布朗克斯区。当他上学并在社区玩耍时，他注意到了一些事情。贫困家庭的孩子有很多误入歧途的途径。在贫困中成长的一点是，你会被邪恶包围，这意味着有些人以诱导好孩子为了钱做坏事为生。即使在小时候，我也一直很好奇，为什么有些孩子会被
seduced and other kids like me were able to resist. Was some kids smarter, tougher? Lots of people might draw such conclusions, but from an early age, Phil found himself interested in another explanation. The context in which a good kid would do something bad, the situation. At school, James Monroe High School also in the Bronx, Phil got close to a classmate who was interested in the same questions. And it was a little Jewish kid named Stanley Milgram. We were in the same class, we sat side by side. He was the smartest kid in the class. He won all the medals at graduation, so obviously nobody liked him because we were all envious
诱惑，而像我这样的其他孩子却能够抵制。是有些孩子更聪明、更强硬吗？很多人可能会得出这样的结论，但菲尔从小就对另一种解释感兴趣。好孩子做坏事的背景，即情境。在布朗克斯的詹姆斯·门罗高中，菲尔与一位对同样问题感兴趣的同学走得很近。他就是那个叫斯坦利·米尔格拉姆的犹太小男孩。我们在同一个班级，并排坐着。他是班上最聪明的孩子。毕业时他赢得了所有的奖牌，所以显然没人喜欢他，因为我们都嫉妒
of him, but he was super smart and super serious. If you know anything about psychology, you will know that these teenagers went on to become two of the most influential psychologists in history. Phil became famous for conducting the Stanford Prison Experiment, where he turned the University Psychology Department into a makeshift prison. Stanley Milgram made his mark with a study that examined the power of situations to seduce good people to do bad things. It involved asking a volunteer to administer a memory test to another person.
他，但他超级聪明，也超级认真。如果你对心理学有所了解，你就会知道这些青少年后来成为了历史上最有影响力的两位心理学家。菲尔因主持斯坦福监狱实验而闻名，他将大学心理学系变成了一个临时监狱。斯坦利·米尔格拉姆则通过一项研究留下了自己的印记，该研究考察了情境诱导好人做坏事的力量。它涉及要求一名志愿者对另一个人进行记忆测试。
If the answers were wrong, the volunteer was told to deliver a series of electrical shocks as punishment. The study has invited a great deal of admiration and a great deal of criticism over the years. We're going to begin today's show by taking you through this famous experiment. As you listen, pay attention to how you're responding to the scene that unfolds, what you think about the different characters, and how you relate to them. Once it's done, we're going to talk with a psychologist who realized that most people overlook something in the experiment.
如果答案错误，志愿者会被要求给予一系列电击作为惩罚。多年来，这项研究招致了大量的赞誉和大量的批评。我们今天节目的开头将带你了解这个著名的实验。在聆听时，请注意你对所展开场景的反应，你对不同角色的看法，以及你如何与他们产生共鸣。结束后，我们将与一位心理学家交谈，她意识到大多数人在实验中忽略了一些东西。
We so often sort of simulate if I was in that Milgram shock experiment what would I do if I was the the study participant, right? Would I actually stand up and go against these directives and say no? But we kind of flipped that idea on its head. Stopping to notice what she noticed can lead us to a vital insight about the mind. The power we exert over others, and the perils of living too much inside our own heads, this week on destroying itself. World War II was raging in Europe and Asia, and by the time he was 8, the US was swept up in the conflict.
我们经常会模拟，如果我身处那个米尔格拉姆电击实验中，如果我是研究参与者，我会怎么做，对吧？我会真的站出来反对这些指令并说不吗？但我们把这个想法颠倒了过来。停下来注意她所注意到的事情，可以引导我们对思维产生重要的洞察。我们对他人的影响力，以及生活在自己头脑中太多的危险，本周在《自我毁灭》中探讨。第二次世界大战在欧洲和亚洲肆虐，到他8岁时，美国也被卷入了这场冲突。
We interrupt this broadcast to bring you this important bulletin from the United Press. A White House announces Japanese attack on 1941, a date which will limp in infamy. By tomorrow morning, the members of Congress will have a four-fourth and be ready for action. The fields of battle were far from Stanley's home, but as he grew older, he couldn't stop thinking about the war and its implications. Stanley was consumed by some big questions. Why did so many people willingly kill Jews in the Holocaust? Was everyone who followed Nazi orders inherently evil?
我们中断广播，为您带来这条来自合众国际社的重要快讯。白宫宣布日本于1941年发动袭击，这是一个将蒙受耻辱的日子。到明天早上，国会议员们将齐聚一堂，准备采取行动。战场离斯坦利的家很远，但随着年龄的增长，他无法停止对战争及其影响的思考。斯坦利被一些重大问题所困扰。为什么那么多人心甘情愿地在大屠杀中杀害犹太人？所有服从纳粹命令的人本质上都是邪恶的吗？
Here he is in an educational film. How was it possible I asked myself that ordinary people were courteous and decent in everyday life, can act callously, inhumanely, without any limitations of conscience? Phil Zimbardo remembers his classmate asking those same questions at James Monroe High School. As a high school student he was worried that the Holocaust could happen again in America. And everybody said, Stanley, that was Nazi Germany, that was then, we're not that kind of people. And he would say, I bet they saw it the same thing.
这是他在一部教育片中的片段。我问自己，在日常生活中彬彬有礼、正派的普通人，怎么可能在没有任何良心限制的情况下，表现得如此冷酷、不人道？菲尔·津巴多记得他的同学在詹姆斯·门罗高中问过同样的问题。作为一名高中生，他担心大屠杀可能会在美国重演。每个人都说，斯坦利，那是纳粹德国，那是过去的事了，我们不是那种人。而他会说，我敢打赌他们当时也是这么看的。
And the bottom line, he says, how do you know how you would act unless you're in the situation? How do you know how you would act unless you're in the situation? Stanley's theory was that the context that people found themselves in shaped their behavior. This went for Nazis, but it went for ordinary people too. Most of us never get to find out if we will behave like Nazis because most of us never find ourselves in situations where we're asked to behave like Nazis. By the early 1960s, as a psychology professor at Yale, Stanley decided to test this idea.
他说，归根结底，除非你身处那种情境，否则你怎么知道你会怎么做？除非你身处那种情境，否则你怎么知道你会怎么做？斯坦利的理论是，人们所处的环境塑造了他们的行为。这适用于纳粹，也适用于普通人。我们大多数人永远无法知道自己是否会像纳粹那样行事，因为我们大多数人从未发现自己处于被要求像纳粹那样行事的境地。到20世纪60年代初，作为耶鲁大学的心理学教授，斯坦利决定验证这个想法。
Stanley wanted to put volunteers in a situation where they would be asked to do something that was clearly wrong. Would they do it? Follow instructions? Obey orders? He came up with a scenario that was simple, ingenious, and wildly controversial. An experimenter wearing a lab coat invited volunteers into a room. The volunteers were told they were part of a study about learning and memory. Some would play the role of teacher, while others would play a student. What you're going to hear next is a recreation of the study using voice actors.
斯坦利想把志愿者置于一种被要求做明显错误事情的情境中。他们会做吗？听从指示？服从命令？他想出了一个简单、巧妙且极具争议的方案。一名穿着实验服的实验员邀请志愿者进入一个房间。志愿者被告知他们是一项关于学习和记忆的研究的一部分。有些人将扮演老师的角色，而另一些人将扮演学生。接下来你将听到的是使用配音演员对该研究的重现。
The dialogue is drawn from a 1962 documentary that describes the experiment. Before we begin, we should know that some listeners may find this section upsetting because it involves descriptions of someone inflicting pain on another person. Also, there are two liberties we've taken in this recreation. First, in the real version of this experiment, the student responded to the teacher's questions by silently flipping a switch. We've given voice to those actions. Second, we've imagined the internal monologues of some of the people in the experiment.
对话摘自一部描述该实验的1962年纪录片。在开始之前，我们应该知道，一些听众可能会觉得这一部分令人不安，因为它涉及对某人向他人施加痛苦的描述。此外，我们在这次重现中采取了两个自由发挥。首先，在实验的真实版本中，学生通过静默地拨动开关来回答老师的问题。我们为这些动作配了音。其次，我们想象了实验中一些人的内心独白。
Those inner voices sound different from the things they say aloud, and you'll hear them both throughout the scene. So, that's a setup for the experiment. Remember, there was an experimenter and two volunteers one playing the role of teacher and the other playing the role of student. The experimenter began by explaining the purpose of the memory test. We want to find out just what effect different people have on each other as teachers and learners and also what effect punishment will have on the learning in this situation.
那些内心声音听起来与他们大声说出来的话不同，你会在整个场景中听到这两者。所以，这就是实验的设置。记住，有一个实验员和两名志愿者，一个扮演老师，另一个扮演学生。实验员首先解释了记忆测试的目的。我们想找出不同的人作为老师和学习者对彼此有什么影响，以及惩罚在这种情况下对学习有什么影响。
The experimenter told the person playing the role of student to sit in a chair. The experimenter strapped down the student's arms and attached an electrode to his wrist. The electrode, the student was told, was connected to a shock generator. Then the experimenter explained. The teacher will read a list of word pairs to you like these. Blue, girl, nice day, fat neck and so forth. You are to try to remember each pair. For the next time through the teacher will read only the first word or the first half of the word pair. The student was asked to remember the second half of the word pair. The experimenter made sure to ask do you have any questions now before we go to the next room
实验员告诉扮演学生角色的人坐在椅子上。实验员绑住了学生的手臂，并在他的手腕上连接了一个电极。学生被告知，电极连接着一个电击发生器。然后实验员解释道。老师会为你读一串词对，比如这些。蓝色、女孩、美好的一天、胖脖子等等。你要试着记住每一对。下一次，老师只会读第一个词或词对的前半部分。学生被要求记住词对的后半部分。实验员确保问，在我们去下一个房间之前，你现在有什么问题吗？
no but i think i should say this uh... about two years ago i was at the veterans hospital in west haven and while there they detected a heart condition there's nothing serious but as long as i'm having these shocks how strong are they how dangerous are they will know although they may be painful they? How dangerous are they? Well, no. Although they may be painful, they're not dangerous. Next, the experimental usher the volunteer playing the role of teacher into another room. He gave him a set of instructions.
没有，但我认为我应该说这个……大约两年前，我在西黑文的退伍军人医院，在那里他们检测出我有心脏病，没什么严重的，但只要我受到这些电击，它们有多强？有多危险？它们会……虽然它们可能会很痛，但它们？它们有多危险？嗯，不。虽然它们可能会很痛，但它们并不危险。接下来，实验员引导扮演老师角色的志愿者进入另一个房间。他给了他一套说明。
You will read each pair of words in this list once to the learner until you've read the entire list. Direct your voice toward the microphone as the rooms are only partly soundproof. Now, if he gives the correct answer, you say correct and go on to the next line. The correct answer is indicated in the right margin. I see. All right. Looks easy enough. The experiment got on the way. Attention learner, your teacher is about to begin the test. Try and remember the word pairs. Ready? Begin. Blue. Girl. Right so far.
你将把这份清单上的每一对词读给学习者听一次，直到你读完整个清单。请将你的声音对准麦克风，因为房间只有部分隔音。现在，如果他给出了正确答案，你说正确并继续下一行。正确答案标在右侧边缘。我明白了。好的。看起来很简单。实验开始了。注意学习者，你的老师即将开始测试。试着记住这些词对。准备好了吗？开始。蓝色。女孩。到目前为止是对的。
Nice. I think day. Fat. But when the person in the other room made a mistake, fat. Was it hat? No. Wet.
美好。我想是白天。胖。但当另一个人在另一个房间犯错时，胖。是帽子吗？不。湿。
The volunteer playing the role of teacher would tell the learner that he was wrong. As punishment, he would administer an electric jolt. Incorrect. You'll now get a shock of 75 volts. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. You'll now get a shock of 75 volts. Oh! This seems nervous. The experimenter in the lab coat, meanwhile, was observing the process.
扮演老师角色的志愿者会告诉学习者他错了。作为惩罚，他会给予一次电击。不正确。你现在将受到75伏的电击。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。哦。你现在将受到75伏的电击。哦！这看起来很紧张。与此同时，穿着实验服的实验员正在观察这个过程。
Please continue. Cool. Okay, I'm pretty sure it's today. Wrong. It's head. 105 volts. Ow! Come on. Can I write it? I don't want to shock you.
请继续。酷。好的，我很确定是今天。错误。是头。105伏。哎哟！拜托。我可以写下来吗？我不想电你。
Teacher, please continue. What should I do? Boat. Wondering how far I go. 5 volts. BOTE. The students trapped in the chair in the other room kept making mistakes. Each time, the experimenter urged the volunteer playing the role of teacher to keep going. To administer a stronger jolt of electricity. Wrong. It's harsh. 150 volts. How? Experimenter, get me out of here. That's all I want.
老师，请继续。我该怎么办？船。想知道我能走多远。5伏。船。被困在另一个房间椅子上的学生不断犯错。每一次，实验员都敦促扮演老师角色的志愿者继续下去。给予更强的电击。错误。是严厉。150伏。怎么会？实验员，让我离开这里。这就是我想要的。
He wants to quit. I told you I had harsh stuff breaking. My heart is starting to bother me now. Get me out of here, please. My heart is starting to bother me. Continue, teacher. Please go on. Confused to go on.
他想退出。我告诉过你我有严厉的东西要打破。我的心脏现在开始困扰我了。请让我离开这里。我的心脏开始困扰我了。继续，老师。请继续。拒绝继续。
He refused to go on. You want me to keep going? The experiment requires you to continue, teacher. Please continue. The next word is sad. Are you gonna stop? Hi, hello. Next word sad. Get this right. Get shot.
他拒绝继续。你想让我继续吗？实验要求你继续，老师。请继续。下一个词是悲伤。你要停下来吗？嗨，你好。下一个词悲伤。答对这个。被电击。
I don't know. Day. Wrong. I'm up to 185. It's like 180. You're gonna stop. Please continue. As the shock increased,
我不知道。白天。错误。我到了185。就像180。你要停下来。请继续。随着电击增加，
so did the pain. And so did the protests coming from the next room. He's got a heart condition in there. I'm going to go. Your choice. Please continue. Now, I got a shock.
痛苦也随之增加。来自隔壁房间的抗议声也随之增加。他那里有心脏病。我要走了。你的选择。请继续。现在，我受到了电击。
A hundred and eighty volts. I can't stand it. I'm not going to kill a man. So are you going to keep shocking him? Poor guy. He's in there screaming. I said before, the shocks may be painful, but they're not dangerous, but he's in there hollering so I can't stand up. What is something happening? You don't have to keep going
一百八十伏。我受不了了。我不会杀人。所以你要继续电他吗？可怜的家伙。他在里面尖叫。我之前说过，电击可能会很痛，但它们并不危险，但他一直在里面大喊大叫，所以我受不了了。发生了什么事吗？你不必继续下去。
The volunteer being asked to administer electric shocks is in a difficult position The experimenter is urging him to continue even as the person in the next room begs to be spared Should he keep going? Or stop? The experiment requires that you continue teacher, whether the learner likes it or not, we must go on until he's learned all the word pairs. I refuse to take responsibility of him getting hurt. I say you don't want the responsibility.
被要求进行电击的志愿者处于一个困难的境地。实验员敦促他继续，即使隔壁房间的人恳求被放过。他应该继续吗？还是停止？实验要求你继续，老师，无论学习者是否喜欢，我们必须继续，直到他学会了所有的词对。我拒绝承担他受伤的责任。我说你不想承担责任。
It's absolutely essential that you continue to. There is too many of them left. Please go on. Who's going to take the responsibility of anything that happens to the gentleman? I am responsible for anything that happens here. Please. As the experiment progressed, the memory test became more demanding. Slow, walk, dance, truck, music, answer Plzmonk. Get this right. I know it's for science, but I don't want to hurt you. Wrong. 195 votes. Let me out of here.
你继续下去是绝对必要的。还有很多没剩下。请继续。谁来承担发生在这个绅士身上的任何事情的责任？我对这里发生的任何事情负责。请。随着实验的进行，记忆测试变得更加苛刻。慢，走，跳舞，卡车，音乐，回答。答对这个。我知道这是为了科学，但我不想伤害你。错误。195伏。让我离开这里。
Continually. I don't know. Well, you've got me. I know it does sir, but I mean you do know what he's getting in for he's up to 195 that's pretty high After the study reached about 330 volts the screams from the next room went silent about 330 volts, the screams from the next room went silent. If the learner doesn't answer in a reasonable time, about 4 or 5 seconds consider the answer wrong and follow the same procedures you had been doing for wrong answers, say wrong, tell them the number of volts, give him the punishment. Go on please with the experiment. Please continue.
继续。我不知道。好吧，你抓到我了。我知道先生，但我的意思是，你确实知道他要面对什么，他已经到了195，这相当高。在研究达到约330伏后，隔壁房间的尖叫声消失了，大约330伏，隔壁房间的尖叫声消失了。如果学习者没有在合理的时间内回答，大约4或5秒，认为答案错误，并遵循你对错误答案所做的相同程序，说错误，告诉他伏特数，给予他惩罚。请继续实验。请继续。
He's breaking. Soft, rug, pillow, hair, grass. Answer, please. Go on, teacher. 360 vaults. I think something's happened to that fellow in there. I didn't get no answer. Definitely. He was ho get no answer. Definitely.
他崩溃了。软，地毯，枕头，头发，草。请回答。继续，老师。360伏。我想那个家伙在里面出事了。我没有得到任何回答。肯定。他当时在……没有得到任何回答。肯定。
He was hollering at less voltage. Can you check to see if he's all right, please? Not once we've started. Please, continue, teacher. In all, Stanley Milgram ran about 20 different iterations of this study over a span of several years. In this version, many of the volunteers playing the role of teacher showed discomfort,
他在较低电压时就在大喊大叫。你能检查一下他是否还好吗，请？一旦我们开始就不能。请，继续，老师。总共，斯坦利·米尔格拉姆在几年内进行了大约20次不同的这项研究迭代。在这个版本中，许多扮演老师角色的志愿者表现出了不适，
but continued with the experiment. More than half went all the way to 450 Vols, even when the screams from the next room went silent, and the student was presumably unconscious. Why didn't the volunteer stop? Stanley later debriefed some of the volunteers. Why didn't you stop anyway? I did stop, but he kept on, keep on. debrief some of the volunteers. If you're familiar with the study, you already know that the student in the other room was an actor and not actually given electric shocks. The screams and cries of protest were carefully timed recordings.
但继续了实验。超过一半的人一直进行到450伏，即使隔壁房间的尖叫声消失了，学生大概已经失去了知觉。为什么志愿者没有停止？斯坦利后来对一些志愿者进行了汇报。你为什么还是没停？我确实停了，但他一直，一直。汇报一些志愿者。如果你熟悉这项研究，你已经知道隔壁房间的学生是一名演员，并没有真正受到电击。尖叫声和抗议声是精心定时的录音。
The only target of the experiment were the volunteers who played the role of teacher, the people who had to administer the shocks. Stanley Milgram's study generated enormous attention and controversy. Admirers drew parallels between the experiment and what happened in Nazi Germany. They said, look, people are sheep. They can be easily misled by demagogues and dictators. Critics of the study said, no, those conclusions are vastly exaggerated. They questioned whether the volunteers actually behave the way the experiment suggested.
实验的唯一目标是扮演老师角色的志愿者，即那些必须进行电击的人。斯坦利·米尔格拉姆的研究引起了巨大的关注和争议。崇拜者在实验和纳粹德国发生的事情之间画了等号。他们说，看，人们是羊。他们很容易被煽动者和独裁者误导。该研究的批评者说，不，这些结论被大大夸大了。他们质疑志愿者是否真的表现得像实验所暗示的那样。
Some critics said that many volunteers simply refused to go along. Beyond the academic debates, the study prompted an entire sub-jandra of books and movies. Even today, people find the study fascinating, and they find it fascinating for one reason. How, they ask, could people who know that something is wrong go along with it? Are such people typical? Is everyone susceptible to such influence? Am I? As we listen to the details of the study, we can't help but ask, what would I do? Would I follow orders and zap the person screaming in the other room? 105 volts.
一些批评者说，许多志愿者只是拒绝配合。除了学术辩论之外，这项研究还引发了整个书籍和电影的子类型。即使在今天，人们仍然觉得这项研究很迷人，而且他们觉得它迷人是因为一个原因。他们问，那些知道某事是错误的人怎么会随波逐流？这样的人是典型的吗？每个人都容易受到这种影响吗？我呢？当我们听研究细节时，我们不禁要问，我会怎么做？我会服从命令并电击隔壁房间尖叫的人吗？105伏。
Ow! Come on, get it right. I don't want to shock you. Peter, please continue. What should I do? But Vanessa Barnes, a psychologist at Cornell University, realized there was something no one was paying attention to. Everyone was asking what was going on in the minds of the volunteers and how difficult the situation was for them. We so often sort of simulate if I was in that Milgram shock experiment, what would I do if I was the study participant, right? Would I actually stand up and go against these directives and say no? No one was asking whether it was difficult for the experiment or wearing the lab coat
哎哟！拜托，答对它。我不想电你。老师，请继续。我该怎么办？但康奈尔大学的心理学家凡妮莎·巴恩斯意识到，有些事情没有人注意。每个人都在问志愿者的脑子里在想什么，以及这种情况对他们来说有多困难。我们经常模拟，如果我身处那个米尔格拉姆电击实验中，我会怎么做，如果我是研究参与者，对吧？我会真的站出来反对这些指令并说不吗？没有人问穿着实验服的实验员是否感到困难
to tell the volunteers to administer electric shocks. To the extent we think of the experiment at all, we might imagine someone who enjoyed putting people in difficult situations, a sort of mad scientist. Vanessa asked a deceptively simple question. Was he surprised to see these people going along with this crazy request he was making of them? Vanessa's insight was radical. What if you looked at the experiment,
去告诉志愿者进行电击。在我们想到实验的程度上，我们可能会想象一个喜欢把人置于困难境地的人，一个疯狂的科学家。凡妮莎问了一个看似简单的问题。他看到这些人顺从他提出的这个疯狂要求时感到惊讶吗？凡妮莎的洞察力是激进的。如果你看这个实验，
not from the point of view of the students screaming in the next room, and not from the point of view of the volunteer administering the shocks, but from the point of view of the person giving the instructions. Teacher, please continue. Is he gonna keep going?
不是从隔壁房间尖叫的学生的角度，也不是从进行电击的志愿者的角度，而是从发出指令的人的角度。老师，请继续。他会继续吗？
Oh, I wonder how far I can go. What if you treated the experimenter as the object of studying once equipped? Continue, teacher. Please go on. The experiment requires you to continue, teacher. Please continue. I said before, the shocks may be painful, but they're not so... Are you going to keep shocking him?
哦，我想知道我能走多远。如果你把实验员当作研究对象会怎样？继续，老师。请继续。实验要求你继续，老师。请继续。我之前说过，电击可能会很痛，但它们并不……你要继续电他吗？
So, stop, stop. You don't have to keep going. Why do so few of us put ourselves in the shoes of the experimenter? Why don't we ask how difficult it was for him to issue those instructions? Why is it, when we hear the story, we automatically put ourselves in the shoes of the volunteers, the people receiving the instructions? Vanessa realized that we all naturally gravitate to the point of view of the volunteers and not the point of view of the experimenter, because we all instinctively know what it feels like to have other people put us in uncomfortable situations.
所以，停下，停下。你不必继续下去。为什么我们中很少有人设身处地为实验员着想？为什么我们不问他发出这些指令有多困难？为什么当我们听到这个故事时，我们会自动把自己放在志愿者的位置上，即接收指令的人？凡妮莎意识到，我们都自然而然地倾向于志愿者的观点，而不是实验员的观点，因为我们都本能地知道让别人把我们置于不舒服的境地是什么感觉。
We think of our bosses, our partners, our co-workers, and how they affect our lives and change our moods. We think of the aggressive driver next to us or the other patrons of the restaurant who are so loud and obnoxious that they ruin our meal. Referee buffeted and pushed and pulled by those around us. The one thing we don't ask, what effect do I have on other people? There's been a long history of research on social influence and persuasion so we do know a lot about how other people influence us, but we don't know so much about how we experience our influence of other people.
我们想到我们的老板、我们的伴侣、我们的同事，以及他们如何影响我们的生活并改变我们的情绪。我们想到旁边的激进司机，或者餐馆里那些大声喧哗、令人讨厌的其他顾客，他们毁了我们的饭局。我们被周围的人推来推去。我们唯一不问的是，我对其他人有什么影响？关于社会影响和说服的研究历史悠久，所以我们确实知道很多关于其他人如何影响我们的信息，但我们对我们如何体验对他人的影响知之甚少。
When we are intensely focused on how the world affects us and not how we affect the world, for both good and evil. When Vanessa Barnes was a graduate student at Columbia University, she worked on a study. Every day, she would leave her apartment in the Morningside Heights neighborhood, get on the subway, and take the one train from 116th Street to Penn Station. Once she was there, she had to do something she found very difficult. Basically, I would just go up to random people on Penn Station, say, hey, we felt this questionnaire. Vanessa no longer remembers what the questionnaire was about, but she can still recall what it felt like to make such requests of total strangers. Yeah, I mean, I still have flashbacks of going down to Penn Station because it was so distressing.
当我们专注于世界如何影响我们，而不是我们如何影响世界时，无论是好是坏。当凡妮莎·巴恩斯在哥伦比亚大学读研究生时，她参与了一项研究。每天，她都会离开晨边高地社区的公寓，坐上地铁，乘坐1号线从116街到宾夕法尼亚车站。一旦到了那里，她就必须做一件她觉得非常困难的事情。基本上，我只是走到宾夕法尼亚车站的随机人面前，说，嘿，我们填了这份问卷。凡妮莎不再记得问卷的内容，但她仍然记得向完全陌生的人提出这种要求是什么感觉。是的，我的意思是，我仍然有去宾夕法尼亚车站的闪回，因为它太令人痛苦了。
I would walk in, people kind of walking all over the place, and then there'd be people just sitting down waiting for their trains. So I'd usually go up to the person who was sitting there waiting for their train, you know, doing whatever they do to kind of occupy their time. And I would say, excuse me, what you please fill out the survey. It felt incredibly awkward, stepping into someone's space, disturbing them, asking them to stop doing what they were doing and to do something she wanted them to do. As Vanessa asked for help and waited for an answer, her palms began to sweat. Her heart started beating faster.
我会走进去，人们到处走动，然后有些人只是坐着等火车。所以我通常会走到坐在那里等火车的人面前，你知道，做他们做的事情来打发时间。我会说，打扰一下，请你填一下调查问卷好吗？这感觉非常尴尬，进入别人的空间，打扰他们，要求他们停止正在做的事情，去做她想让他们做的事情。当凡妮莎寻求帮助并等待回答时，她的手心开始出汗。她的心跳开始加快。
It was a really sort of palpable fear that they were going to reject me or worse, right? Say something mean. I don't even know what, but I expected them to say something terrible. Looking back on the moment now, it reminds her of another Stanley Milgram study, one that's less famous than the obedience experiment.
这是一种非常明显的恐惧，他们会拒绝我，或者更糟，对吧？说些刻薄的话。我甚至不知道是什么，但我预料他们会说些可怕的话。现在回顾那一刻，这让她想起了斯坦利·米尔格拉姆的另一项研究，一项不如服从实验出名的研究。
He had his research assistants go on to New York City subways and ask people for their seats. Many of the students couldn't complete the task. His students started coming back to him saying, I can't do this, this is just so upsetting, this is the most, you know, distressing thing you've ever asked me to do. And he was like, you guys are being babies. I don't understand why this is so upsetting. And so, to prove his students wrong, the famous researcher set out for the subway himself. He would do what his students couldn't, walk up to strangers, and ask them for their seats.
他让他的研究助理去纽约市的地铁上，向人们要座位。许多学生无法完成任务。他的学生回来对他说，我做不到，这太令人不安了，这是你要求我做的最令人痛苦的事情。他说，你们这些家伙真是孩子气。我不明白为什么这这么令人不安。所以，为了证明他的学生错了，这位著名的研究员亲自去了地铁。他会做他的学生做不到的事，走到陌生人面前，向他们要座位。
He found the experience so much more distressing than he expected it to be, and all of a sudden he understood why they have been complaining so much. Why is it so hard to make such requests? Well, one obvious explanation is that we know that people will reject us, and that rejection is painful. Vanessa remembers being hugely relieved when she was done giving out questionnaires at Penn Station and could head back to her lab at Columbia University. Once there, she and her professor, Frank Flynn, analyzed the responses to the questionnaire. They noticed something intriguing.
他发现这种经历比他预期的要痛苦得多，突然间他明白了为什么他们抱怨得那么多。为什么提出这样的要求这么难？嗯，一个明显的解释是，我们知道人们会拒绝我们，而这种拒绝是痛苦的。凡妮莎记得当她在宾夕法尼亚车站发完问卷并可以回到哥伦比亚大学的实验室时，她感到无比轻松。到了那里，她和她的教授弗兰克·弗林分析了问卷的回答。他们注意到了一些有趣的事情。
Frank was like, I can't believe how many people are actually saying yes to you. Total strangers disrupted from reading their newspaper or eating a sandwich or watching the crowds of people in the busy station, they were like, sure, I'll respond to your questionnaire. We were really surprised by how many people were agreeing in New York Penn Station to do this survey. What began as a simple observation turned into something much more important and insight about our minds.
弗兰克说，我不敢相信有多少人真的对你说好。完全陌生的人被中断阅读报纸、吃三明治或看着繁忙车站里的人群，他们说，当然，我会回答你的问卷。我们真的很惊讶在纽约宾夕法尼亚车站有这么多人同意做这项调查。从一个简单的观察开始，变成了一些更重要的事情，即对我们思想的洞察。
Here's the chain of thought that led to the discovery. The reason Frank and Vanessa was surprised that so many people said yes is because they expected people to say no. If lots of people said yes, that meant that Vanessa's fears about rejection were misplaced, her perception of the influence she actually had on other people was wrong. Like most of us, Vanessa had long felt that others had a big effect on her. As she gazed at the data, she realized that she had a big effect on other people. If she was blind to this power, what consequences could it have on her behavior?
这是导致这一发现的思维链。弗兰克和凡妮莎对这么多人说好感到惊讶的原因是，他们预料人们会说不。如果很多人说好，那就意味着凡妮莎对拒绝的恐惧是错误的，她对自己对他人的实际影响的感知是错误的。像我们大多数人一样，凡妮莎长期以来一直觉得别人对她有很大的影响。当她凝视数据时，她意识到她对其他人有很大的影响。如果她对这种力量视而不见，它会对她的行为产生什么后果？
As researchers, the first thing that Vanessa and Frank decided to do was test if that personal experience was generalizable. We decided to bring participants into the lab and have them do basically what I had done on those number of days. So we brought them into the lab. We said, hey, we're going to have you go out and ask people to as our first step fill out a survey just like I had
作为研究人员，凡妮莎和弗兰克决定做的第一件事是测试这种个人经历是否具有普遍性。我们决定把参与者带进实验室，让他们基本上做我在那些日子里所做的事情。所以我们把他们带进实验室。我们说，嘿，我们要让你出去，要求人们作为第一步填一份调查问卷，就像我做的那样。
done. And how many people do you think are going to say yes to you? We made them estimate how many people they thought would agree, go out and actually ask people, and what we found was that they really underestimated the number of people who would agree to that request. So it wasn't just Vanessa and Frank. People in general seem to have a poor assessment of their power over others. People thought that others would find it easy to turn down their requests. Vanessa connected the seeming blind spot in our thinking to Stanley Milgram's famous obedience study. She realized this might be why everyone
你认为有多少人会对你说好？我们让他们估计他们认为有多少人会同意，出去并真正要求人们，我们发现他们确实低估了同意该请求的人数。所以不仅仅是凡妮莎和弗兰克。人们普遍似乎对自己对他人的力量评估很差。人们认为其他人会发现拒绝他们的要求很容易。凡妮莎将我们思维中看似盲点的地方与斯坦利·米尔格拉姆著名的服从研究联系起来。她意识到这可能就是为什么每个人
always saw the experiment from the perspective of the volunteers asked to administer shocks, the people being influenced. No one saw the experiment from the point of view of the experimenter, the person exercising influence. We don't ask, was it hard for him to issue those crazy instructions because we don't identify with people exercising such influence? We think that kind of person must be very different from us because we don't feel we have such power. Was he surprised to see these people going along with this crazy request he was making
总是从被要求进行电击的志愿者的角度，即被影响的人的角度来看待实验。没有人从实验员的角度，即行使影响力的人的角度来看待实验。我们不问，他发出那些疯狂的指令对他来说很难吗，因为我们不认同行使这种影响力的人。我们认为那种人一定和我们很不一样，因为我们不觉得我们有这种力量。他看到这些人顺从他提出的这个疯狂要求时感到惊讶吗？
of them? So it's interesting when people think about the Stanley Milgram study, I think this is true for myself as well. I always imagine myself being in the role of the volunteer in the experiment, hearing the instructions from the experimenter saying, you must shock this other person, I never put myself in the shoes of the experimenter. Exactly. So that was something that we started to wonder about. So we so often sort of simulate if I was in that Milgram shock experiment,. So we so often sort of simulate, if I was in that Milgram shock experiment, what would I do if I was the study participant, right?
所以当人们想到斯坦利·米尔格拉姆的研究时，这很有趣，我想我自己也是如此。我总是想象自己扮演实验中志愿者的角色，听到实验员的指令说，你必须电击另一个人，我从来没有设身处地为实验员着想。完全正确。所以这是我们开始好奇的事情。所以我们经常模拟，如果我身处那个米尔格拉姆电击实验中，如果我是研究参与者，我会怎么做，对吧？
Would I actually stand up and go against these directives and say no? But we kind of flipped that idea on its head. Vanessa went back to her experience at Penn Station. It felt difficult because she had seen the interaction only from the point of view of her own insecurities. She hadn't seen the encounters through the point of view of the people she was asking for help. From their perspective, an anxious young woman was asking for something trivial.
我会真的站出来反对这些指令并说不吗？但我们把这个想法颠倒了过来。凡妮莎回到了她在宾夕法尼亚车站的经历。这感觉很困难，因为她只从自己不安全感的角度看待互动。她没有从她寻求帮助的人的角度看待这些遭遇。从他们的角度来看，一个焦虑的年轻女子在要求一些琐碎的事情。
They had to weigh whether to put aside what they were doing and help her for a few minutes. If they said no, it could make them look like jerks. It's this really interesting phenomenon where you have these two people interacting with one another and they're both so focused on their own personal anxieties and insecurities and concerns with embarrassment that they don't realize that the other person is feeling that way too.
他们必须权衡是否要放下手头的事情，帮她几分钟。如果他们说不，这可能会让他们看起来像混蛋。这是一个非常有趣的现象，你有这两个人互相互动，他们都如此专注于自己的个人焦虑、不安全感和对尴尬的担忧，以至于他们没有意识到对方也有这种感觉。
So it's this really interesting situation where being so inwardly focused on your own anxieties makes it so difficult for you to recognize what the situation really is for itself. People in these encounters experience what psychologists call an egocentric bias. They are so consumed with their own perceptions that they fail to see what the interaction feels like for the other person. It's absolutely true that many of us are influenced by situations that many of us will do things because the situation prompts it. But there is another problem too, and it might be a deeper problem. The people who put us in those situations,
所以这是一个非常有趣的情况，如此专注于自己的焦虑使得你很难认识到情况本身到底是什么。在这些遭遇中，人们体验到心理学家所说的自我中心偏见。他们如此沉浸在自己的感知中，以至于他们无法看到互动对另一个人来说是什么感觉。我们中的许多人确实受到情境的影响，我们中的许多人会因为情境的提示而做事情，这绝对是真的。但还有另一个问题，这可能是一个更深层的问题。把我们置于这些情境中的人，
it's not like they are all powerful gods. They are humans just like us, and they may not realize the extent of the power they have over us. In fact, they may be thinking, I'm sure this person is going to turn down my request. They might assume falsely that it's easy to refuse instructions. When I said realized that this bias could have all sorts of important consequences. So what we started looking at about over a decade now ago, we started to look at whether we recognize when we're the ones who are influencing someone else. When we recognize that someone else, for example,
他们并不是全能的神。他们和我们一样是人类，他们可能没有意识到他们对我们拥有的力量程度。事实上，他们可能在想，我相信这个人会拒绝我的请求。他们可能会错误地假设拒绝指令很容易。当我意识到这种偏见可能会产生各种重要的后果时。所以我们开始研究大约十年前的事情，我们开始研究当我们是影响他人的人时，我们是否能意识到。当我们意识到其他人，例如，
can't say no to something that we've asked them. Vanessa has now a psychologist at Cornell University. In a series of experiments, she has demonstrated how people are often oblivious to the power that they have over others. In one study, she asked volunteers, mostly college students, to make a simple request of others. We brought people into the lab and we told them you're going to go out into campus and ask people to borrow their phones. She walked them through how to approach someone and gave them instructions for what to do once people agreed to let them use their phones. They would call us back at the lab and say, I have this person's phone, this is where I'm located, we'd mark it down and then they go on and ask somebody else. Before the volunteers went out to begin the study,
不能拒绝我们要求他们做的事情。凡妮莎现在是康奈尔大学的心理学家。在一系列实验中，她展示了人们往往对他们对他人的力量视而不见。在一项研究中，她要求志愿者，主要是大学生，对他人提出一个简单的请求。我们把人们带进实验室，告诉他们你要去校园，要求人们借用他们的手机。她引导他们如何接近某人，并给他们说明，一旦人们同意让他们使用手机，该怎么做。他们会打回实验室说，我有这个人的手机，这是我的位置，我们记下来，然后他们继续要求别人。在志愿者出去开始研究之前，
Vanessa asked them a question. How many people would they have to ask to get three people to say yes? And at this time, participants are kind of freaked out by this whole thought. They are convinced everyone's gonna say no, they're not gonna be able to do the task. And before they actually go out onto campus to do the task,
凡妮莎问了他们一个问题。他们必须要求多少人才能让三个人说好？而这一次，参与者对整个想法感到非常害怕。他们确信每个人都会说不，他们将无法完成任务。在他们真正去校园做任务之前，
they often would ask us, well, what if no one agrees? do I come back? What do I do? They have all these concerns about not being able to complete the task. What Vanessa found was similar to her own experience at Penn Station. Many more people said yes, than the volunteers expected. They thought they had to ask a little over 10. They actually had to ask more like six. In fact, every other person was agreeing to this request. Maybe you think the students had a high success rate because they were requesting something trivial. But Vanessa has also conducted a version of the study where volunteers had
他们经常会问我们，嗯，如果没有人同意怎么办？我回来吗？我该怎么办？他们有所有关于无法完成任务的担忧。凡妮莎发现的情况与她在宾夕法尼亚车站的经历相似。说好的人比志愿者预期的要多得多。他们认为他们必须要求10个多一点。他们实际上必须要求6个左右。事实上，每隔一个人就会同意这个请求。也许你认为学生有很高的成功率，因为他们要求的是琐碎的事情。但凡妮莎也进行了该研究的一个版本，志愿者必须
to ask for something more consequential. Money. For that study, she enlisted the help of the leukemia and lymphoma societies team in training program. What people do when they participate in a fundraising activity for team in training is they ask people for donations so that they can participate in some sort of race like a triathlon or a marathon. They get some training and some travel money to be able to do that and the rest of the money actually goes to the organization. Vanessa asked participants how many people they would have to solicit to meet their fundraising
要求一些更重要的东西。钱。对于那项研究，她寻求了白血病和淋巴瘤协会团队培训计划的帮助。当人们参加团队培训的筹款活动时，他们会向人们寻求捐款，以便他们可以参加某种比赛，如铁人三项或马拉松。他们得到一些培训和一些差旅费来做到这一点，其余的钱实际上归组织所有。凡妮莎问参与者他们必须向多少人募捐才能达到他们的筹款
goals, which were typically thousands of dollars. They estimated they would need to ask about 200 people to meet the goal. What we found is that they actually only had to ask about half that, so they only had to ask about 100 people in order to reach their fundraising goals. Just as in Vanessa's phone study, her participants doubled the number of people they thought they had to ask to reach their goal. Their egocentric bias caused them to focus so much on their own anxieties that they ignored the influence they actually had over other people.
目标，通常是数千美元。他们估计他们需要要求大约200人才能达到目标。我们发现他们实际上只需要要求大约一半，所以他们只需要要求大约100人就能达到他们的筹款目标。就像在凡妮莎的手机研究中一样，她的参与者将他们认为必须要求才能达到目标的人数增加了一倍。他们的自我中心偏见导致他们如此专注于自己的焦虑，以至于他们忽略了他们对他人的实际影响。
You're thinking about what you're asking. I'm asking this person for money. Will this person give me money? What you're not doing is thinking about what if you were sitting there, you know, potentially in your cubicle and a co-worker came up to you and said, hey, I'm participating in a race. Would you be willing to sponsor me? If you were sitting there, it'd be really hard to say no to your co-worker, right? It'd be really hard to let them down. It'd be really awkward. What would you even say? And so people are kind of put on the spot and they find it really difficult to say no, so they go ahead and agree. At the University of Chicago, economists John List has also studied the relationship between social pressure and charitable giving.
你在想你要求的是什么。我正在向这个人要钱。这个人会给我钱吗？你没有做的是思考如果你坐在那里，你知道，可能在你的隔间里，一个同事走过来对你说，嘿，我正在参加一场比赛。你愿意赞助我吗？如果你坐在那里，拒绝你的同事会非常困难，对吧？让他们失望会非常困难。这会非常尴尬。你甚至会说什么？所以人们有点被置于聚光灯下，他们发现拒绝真的很难，所以他们继续同意。在芝加哥大学，经济学家约翰·利斯特也研究了社会压力与慈善捐赠之间的关系。
John ran a study where experimenters knocked on the doors of some 8,000 houses in the Chicago area. They were trying to raise money for a children's hospital. John asked me to imagine the scenario from the point of view of the person receiving the request. Let's say it's a Sunday afternoon. I just made myself something to eat. I'm relaxed. You're sitting on the couch watching a football game and you hear somebody knocking on the door.
约翰进行了一项研究，实验人员敲开了芝加哥地区约8000户人家的大门。他们试图为一家儿童医院筹款。约翰让我从接受请求者的角度来想象这个场景。假设现在是周日下午。我刚吃完东西，正放松着。你坐在沙发上看橄榄球比赛，突然听到有人敲门。
And you think, okay, should I get up or should I stay watching the football games? Of course, a lot of people get up and answer the door. But once they see that there's a solicitor at the door, they say, oh my God, I wish I would have stayed on the couch watching the football game. Too late. If they tell the solicitor, no, then they have this very negative or dis-utility from letting someone down. So they're weighing that off versus just giving them $20 and having them go on their way. John added a very interesting twist to the study. Some households were told ahead of time that a fundraising volunteer would come and knock
你会想，好吧，我是该起身去开门，还是继续看比赛？当然，很多人会起身去开门。但一旦他们看到门口站着募捐者，他们就会想，天哪，我真希望自己当时留在沙发上看比赛。太晚了。如果他们拒绝募捐者，就会因为让对方失望而产生非常负面的情绪或“负效用”。所以他们会在这种负面情绪与直接给20美元打发对方走之间进行权衡。约翰为这项研究增加了一个非常有趣的转折。一些住户被提前告知会有募捐志愿者来敲门。
on the door. Others were not told ahead of time, they just received an unexpected knock. What we find is that when we warn them, of course, many people just stay on the couch or they leave the house. They never answer the house. They never answer the door. The people who do answer the door, they do tend to give money. And much of that is because of altruistic reasons.
另一些人则没有被提前告知，他们只是收到了突如其来的敲门声。我们发现，当我们提前警告他们时，当然，许多人会选择留在沙发上或离开家。他们根本不去开门。而那些确实去开门的人，往往会捐钱。这很大程度上是出于利他主义的原因。
But the people who we do not warn, they end up answering the door more often and they give more. Put another way. People understand how they are going to feel when they put on the spot. They often will go to great lengths to avoid getting in such situations. What this also means is that some significant portion of the money that charities raise might not come from altruism. In the case of the children's hospital fundraiser, for example, what you find is that roughly three quarters of the dollars given are due to social pressure and a quarter of the dollars given is actually due to altruism. So a very small component of what we observe in our door to door fundraising drive is actually driven by altruism.
但那些我们没有提前警告的人，最终开门的频率更高，捐款也更多。换句话说，人们明白当他们被当场要求时会有什么感觉。他们往往会竭尽全力避免陷入这种境地。这也意味着慈善机构筹集到的很大一部分资金可能并非来自利他主义。以这家儿童医院的筹款活动为例，你发现大约四分之三的捐款是由于社会压力，而只有四分之一的捐款是真正出于利他主义。因此，我们在上门募捐活动中观察到的行为，只有很小一部分是由利他主义驱动的。
in our door to door fundraising drive is actually driven by altruism. John's research reminds Vanessa of a classic study where researchers set up two boots on a college campus. One booth was clearly asking people for something while the other did not ask for anything. What the researchers found was similar to John's donation study. They measured how far away people walked from the booth as they walked by this path. And if people knew that they were going to be asked for something, their distance from the booth was much further than if they didn't think they were going to be asked for something, we just kind of avoid any chance of having to say no to somebody. We've seen how egocentric buyers can cause us to act in helpful ways to others.
在我们的上门募捐活动中，实际上是由利他主义驱动的。约翰的研究让凡妮莎想起了一项经典研究，研究人员在大学校园里设置了两个摊位。一个摊位明确向人们索要东西，而另一个则什么都不要求。研究人员发现的结果与约翰的捐赠研究类似。他们测量了人们在经过这条路时距离摊位有多远。如果人们知道自己会被索要东西，他们与摊位的距离会比他们认为自己不会被索要东西时远得多，我们只是在某种程度上避免任何不得不拒绝别人的机会。我们已经看到自我中心偏差如何导致我们以对他人的帮助方式行事。
We lend phones to people who need them or donate money to charity. Unfortunately though, there's another side to the story. They grabbed that headset and they threw it across the room. When we come back, the sinister side of our inability to recognize our power over other people. When we interact with others, we are often intensely focused on how we feel. Our anxieties, our embarrassments, our fears. As a result, we are often blind to the effect we have on others, their anxieties, their embarrassments, and their fears.
我们把手机借给需要的人，或者向慈善机构捐款。但不幸的是，故事还有另一面。他们抓起那个耳机，把它扔过房间。当我们回来时，我们将探讨我们无法认识到自己对他人的权力所带来的阴暗面。当我们与他人互动时，我们往往过于关注自己的感受。我们的焦虑、尴尬和恐惧。结果，我们往往对我们对他人的影响视而不见，看不到他们的焦虑、尴尬和恐惧。
Psychologists venous abons a studied how such egocentric bias can keep people from asking for help. But that's not the whole story. There's kind of the happy story, which is that people will help us more than we think. And then there's kind of the darker story that people will do a lot of other things for us more so than we think.
心理学家凡妮莎·邦斯研究了这种自我中心偏差如何阻止人们寻求帮助。但这并不是故事的全部。有一种“快乐的故事”，即人们会比我们想象的更愿意帮助我们。还有一种“更黑暗的故事”，即人们会比我们想象的更愿意为我们做很多其他事情。
So we've run some studies where we started out kind of asking people if they could get someone to lie for them. So our original studies involved, you know, just filling something out. We said, what if we just have them ask if they'll, you know, sign their name to say to something saying that you gave them a pitch that you didn't actually give them. Just kind of a white lie. And so once again, we had people guess how many people they would have to ask this or make this request of before a certain number said yes, they went out onto campus, they asked people you know, I'm supposed to be doing this pitch, I really don't feel like doing it, were you just sign this saying that I gave you the pitch? And again, most people wound up signing it even though our participants thought that most people would say no.
所以我们进行了一些研究，开始时我们询问人们是否能让别人为他们撒谎。我们最初的研究涉及，你知道，只是填写一些东西。我们说，如果我们只是让他们问对方是否愿意，你知道，签个名说你给他们做了推销，而实际上你并没有做。这只是一种善意的谎言。所以我们再次让人们猜测在一定数量的人同意之前，他们必须询问多少人。他们走到校园里，问人们，你知道，我应该做这个推销，但我真的不想做，你能不能签个名说我给你做了推销？结果，大多数人最终还是签了名，尽管我们的参与者认为大多数人会拒绝。
As Vanessa says, the volunteers were asking people to tell a trivia lie. And perhaps you could say, what's the big deal in signing a note that says someone gave you a pitch that they didn't? There are no real moral consequences. So Vanessa raised the stakes. We kind of upped the stakes. We kind of up the ante. And so what we did is we created these fake library books. We took a bunch of books off my bookshelf and just, you know, put some library codes on them. And we gave them to participants and we said,
正如凡妮莎所说，志愿者们要求人们撒一个琐碎的谎。也许你会说，签个字说某人给你做了推销，而实际上没有，这有什么大不了的？这没有真正的道德后果。所以凡妮莎提高了赌注。我们提高了赌注。我们提高了筹码。所以我们所做的是制作了这些伪造的图书馆书籍。我从书架上拿了一堆书，你知道，贴上了一些图书馆代码。我们把它们交给参与者，然后说，
we're going to have you go into the libraries on campus and ask people to vandalize these library books. And so they were to tell people, I'm playing a prank on my friend, but they know my handwriting. Will you please just write pickle in this library book and pen? And they left it at that and looked at whether or not
我们要让你去校园里的图书馆，要求人们破坏这些图书馆书籍。他们要告诉人们，我在和朋友开玩笑，但他们认得我的笔迹。你能请用钢笔在这本图书馆书里写上“泡菜”吗？他们就此打住，并观察是否
people agreed. And what we found is that the people they approached, so they kept track of sort of the things that people said when they made this request of them. And people would say things like, this is wrong, you shouldn't be doing this, we could get in trouble, they were clearly uncomfortable with the prospect
人们同意了。我们发现，他们接触的人——他们记录了人们在提出这个请求时所说的话。人们会说诸如“这是不对的，你不应该这样做，我们可能会惹上麻烦”之类的话，他们显然对破坏这本所谓的图书馆书籍的前景感到不舒服，
of vandalizing this purported library book, but they still did it. They still did it. And again, that finding went completely against the intuitions of the volunteers doing the asking. People significantly underestimated how much influence they possessed to get others to do something unethical. So our participants, before they went out
但他们还是做了。他们还是做了。同样，这一发现完全违背了进行询问的志愿者的直觉。人们严重低估了自己拥有多大的影响力来让别人做一些不道德的事情。所以我们的参与者，在他们出去
and started asking people, they thought about 28% of people would agree to do this, right? So they thought the vast majority of people would say no. But when they actually went out and made this request of people, 64%, a majority of the people they asked actually agreed to vandalize this library book. I mean, that's actually pretty astonishing that 64% of people would say yes. I mean, I would not have predicted it would be as high a number as that. Yeah, I mean, this was a task we designed and we were like, this is never going to work.
开始询问别人之前，他们认为大约28%的人会同意这样做，对吧？所以他们认为绝大多数人会拒绝。但当他们真正走出去向人们提出这个请求时，64%的人，即大多数被询问的人，实际上同意破坏这本图书馆书籍。我的意思是，64%的人会说“是”，这确实相当令人震惊。我的意思是，我不会预测到数字会这么高。是的，我的意思是，这是我们设计的一个任务，我们当时想，这永远不会成功。
There's no way people are actually going to agree to do this. And we ourselves were completely surprised that that people did agree. As much as it was uncomfortable for them to do this unethical thing and analyze a library book, it was way more uncomfortable for them to say no to the person who was asking. The scenarios in which eco-centric bias could play a role in our behavior seem endless. We share the answers to our homework with a friend who asked to see our work. We don't push back when a colleague suggests bending the rules on a time sheet. We agree to keep a friend's infidelity a secret even when it makes us uncomfortable.
人们不可能真的同意这样做。我们自己也完全惊讶于人们竟然同意了。尽管做这种不道德的事情和破坏图书馆书籍让他们感到不舒服，但拒绝那个提出请求的人让他们感到更加不舒服。自我中心偏差在我们的行为中可能发挥作用的场景似乎无穷无尽。我们与要求看我们作业的朋友分享答案。当同事建议在工时表上弄虚作假时，我们不会反驳。我们同意为朋友保守婚外情的秘密，即使这让我们感到不舒服。
Listening to Vanessa made me realize why there is a vast gulf between what we predict we might do and what we actually do when we are confronted with problematic behavior. We look as outsiders at the situation and we say why would you tolerate this? Why wouldn't you just stand up and say I'm not going to do this? I'm not going to hurt another person or you know, I need to be able to do my job and you're affecting my ability to do my job. But in fact, the social pressure,
听了凡妮莎的话，我意识到为什么在我们预测自己可能会做什么与面对有问题行为时实际所做的事情之间存在巨大的鸿沟。我们作为局外人审视这种情况，我们会说，你为什么要容忍这种事？你为什么不站出来说“我不会这样做”？我不会伤害另一个人，或者你知道，我需要能够做好我的工作，而你正在影响我做好工作的能力。但事实上，社会压力，
the concern about offending another person, the social anxiety in that situation is so palpable to that individual, but it feels almost impossible for them to stand up and say something and get about it and reject the sort of behavior that they're encountering. Hidden Brain Lysner Anna Aburus called in with a story that illustrates how egocentric bias can affect workplace behavior. She was training to be an air traffic controller and saw examples of bullying and harassing behavior all around her. She says the trainers had a clear message for trainees.
对冒犯他人的担忧，在这种情况下产生的社交焦虑对个人来说是如此明显，以至于他们觉得站出来说点什么并拒绝他们所遇到的那种行为几乎是不可能的。Hidden Brain的听众安娜·阿布鲁斯打来电话，讲述了一个说明自我中心偏差如何影响工作场所行为的故事。她当时正在接受空中交通管制员的培训，并看到了周围欺凌和骚扰行为的例子。她说，培训师对学员有一个明确的信息。
Don't be soft. Or you know you got to have thick skin to survive in air traffic. That was a common one for sure. You have to have thick skin to survive in air traffic. I've heard that over a hundred times. Anna recalled one painful incident. There was a trainee that was trying
不要软弱。或者你知道，你必须脸皮厚才能在空中交通领域生存。这绝对是一个常见的说法。你必须脸皮厚才能在空中交通领域生存。我听过不下百次了。安娜回忆起一次痛苦的经历。有一名学员试图
to clear an aircraft for landing. And the trainer in that moment grabbed the headset of the trainee. And this headset is plugged in to the radar. And they grabbed that headset and they threw it across the room, which would fly off of the training. They would actually tell them, hey hurry up and go grab it
指挥一架飞机降落。那一刻，培训师抓住了学员的耳机。这个耳机是插在雷达上的。他们抓起那个耳机，把它扔过房间，耳机从学员头上飞了出去。他们甚至会告诉他们，嘿，快点去把它捡起来，
so that you can plug back in and clear this aircraft for landing. Anna says seeing such incidents made her fearful. She didn't feel she could complain since such behaviors appear to be the norm. Who could she complain to? The people who were themselves acting badly? They would just say things like, what are you doing? Um, stop f***ing up.
这样你才能插回去并指挥这架飞机降落。安娜说，看到这样的事件让她感到恐惧。她觉得无法投诉，因为这种行为似乎是常态。她能向谁投诉呢？那些本身行为就很恶劣的人吗？他们只会说诸如“你在干什么？嗯，别再搞砸了。”
You f***ing idiot. If you do that again, I swear f***ing God. One time when she was directing aircraft, this was in real life, not a simulation. She found herself sitting next to one of the trainers who she says had acted abusively to her trainees. By this point, Anna was no longer a trainee. She was directing to aircraft.
“你这个该死的白痴。如果你再那样做，我发誓……”有一次，当她在指挥飞机时，这是在现实生活中，而不是模拟。她发现自己坐在其中一位培训师旁边，她说这位培训师曾对她的学员表现出虐待行为。到这个时候，安娜已经不再是学员了。她正在指挥飞机。
One was a thousand feet above the other. I got the names of the aircraft mixed up. And I, because I was so nervous, I think, and I descended the wrong aircraft. I descended the one on top instead of the one on the bottom, because I got those call signs messed up. She told the aircraft that was at a higher altitude to descend directly into the path
一架飞机在另一架上方一千英尺。我把飞机的名字搞混了。我想是因为我太紧张了，我让错误的飞机下降了。我让上面那架下降，而不是下面那架，因为我把呼号搞乱了。她告诉处于较高高度的飞机直接下降到
of the lower altitude aircraft. Luckily, the pilot could see the aircraft, so the pilot was just said, no, we're not going to descend. And I immediately knew what I had just done. And I thought today was a clear day. It was clear skies. There was no clouds in the way. There was no storm clouds in the way.
较低高度飞机的航线上。幸运的是，飞行员能看到那架飞机，所以飞行员只是说，不，我们不会下降。我立刻意识到我刚刚做了什么。我想那天是个晴天。天空晴朗。没有云挡路。没有风暴云挡路。
But had there been storm clouds? Or had there been some other kind of visual obstruction, this plane would have descended, and they would have hit that aircraft. And I would have been responsible for hundreds of deaths. And it wasn't because I didn't know how to control the traffic I did, and I had done this a million times. It was because of the social stress that I was in at that time that didn't make me think clearly.
但如果当时有风暴云呢？或者如果有其他某种视觉障碍，这架飞机就会下降，它们就会撞上那架飞机。而我将对数百人的死亡负责。这并不是因为我不知道如何控制交通，我知道，而且我已经做过一百万次了。这是因为我当时承受的社会压力，让我无法清晰地思考。
I told Vanessa Barnes what Anna described, how the mere presence of the trainer had disrupted her to the point where she made a mistake that could have been catastrophic. Vanessa said, look, it's certainly the case that there are lots of unethical people who know they are unethical and lots of bullies who know they are bullies. Maybe that was the case here, but there is a deeper problem in the workplace that we often forget.
我告诉凡妮莎·邦斯安娜所描述的情况，培训师的存在是如何干扰她到让她犯下可能导致灾难性后果的错误的程度。凡妮莎说，看，确实有很多不道德的人知道自己不道德，也有很多欺凌者知道自己是欺凌者。也许这里的情况就是这样，但工作场所中存在一个我们经常忽略的更深层次的问题。
The bullies and harassers who don't know that they are bullies and harassers. Often, when we're the person causing someone else to stress, we can't see that distress. It's invisible to us. And it's not to let anybody off the hook because clearly it's the people creating this toxic cultures, responsibility to kind of fix it and to not cause these things to happen.
那些不知道自己是欺凌者和骚扰者的欺凌者和骚扰者。通常，当我们是给别人造成压力的人时，我们看不到那种痛苦。它对我们来说是隐形的。这并不是要让任何人逃避责任，因为显然，创造这种有毒文化的人有责任去修复它，并避免让这些事情发生。
But there's also this cognitive bias there where we may not realize the extent to which we're interfering with somebody else's performance. These same dynamics play out in another common occurrence in the workplace, unwanted romantic attention. We ran a couple of studies where we asked people about their experiences being asked out at work or asking someone out at work. And we asked people to imagine situations where they weren't interested in the other person
但这里也存在一种认知偏差，我们可能没有意识到我们在多大程度上干扰了别人的表现。同样的动态在工作场所的另一种常见现象中上演，即不受欢迎的浪漫关注。我们进行了一些研究，询问人们在工作中被约会或约会别人的经历。我们让人们想象他们对对方不感兴趣的情况，
or the other person wasn't interested in them. And what we found is that people who asked somebody out at work and were rejected thought that it was pretty easy for that person to reject them. They didn't think that that person experienced a whole lot of distress and they didn't think that they changed their behavior very much after being asked out. But when people were called situations where they were asked out by someone at work who they weren't interested in, they described feeling obligated to say yes, feeling much more uncomfortable saying no to the person. And they reported doing all sorts of things to try to avoid that person that the other person didn't realize that they were doing. sorts of things to try to avoid that person that
或者对方对他们不感兴趣的情况。我们发现，在工作中约会别人并被拒绝的人认为，对方拒绝他们是相当容易的。他们不认为对方经历了太多的痛苦，也不认为对方在被约会后改变了多少行为。但当人们回忆起在工作中被自己不感兴趣的人约会的情况时，他们描述说感到有义务说“是”，拒绝对方让他们感到更加不舒服。他们报告说做了各种各样的事情来试图避开那个人，而对方并没有意识到他们在这样做。
the other person didn't realize that they were doing. So in fact, this little request, you know, we tell people to just go for it and ask this person out, it actually puts a lot more pressure on the other person than we tend to realize when we're the ones doing the asking. In some ways, we underestimate the pressure that we exert on other people. In some ways, that's the moral of the whole story, isn't it? Absolutely. Yeah, we underestimate the influence that we have over other people,
对方并没有意识到他们在这样做。所以事实上，这个小小的请求，你知道，我们告诉人们“去吧，约那个人”，实际上给对方施加了比我们作为提出请求的人所意识到的更大的压力。在某种程度上，我们低估了我们对他人施加的压力。在某种程度上，这就是整个故事的寓意，不是吗？绝对是。是的，我们低估了我们对他人的影响力，
and we underestimate the extent to which asking them for something really puts them in an awkward position, because now they have to say no, and that's just a really hard thing for people to do. Like many psychological biases, the tendency we have to downplay the influence we have on others can have far-reaching consequences. It can keep us from asking for help that would be forthcoming. It can keep us from reaching out and making friends with strangers. And it can also lead us to give into unethical demands or making proper demands of other people. I asked Vanessa how her research had prompted her to do things differently in her own life. It has made a huge difference in the little things.
我们也低估了向他们索要东西在多大程度上真的让他们处于尴尬的境地，因为现在他们必须说“不”，而这对人们来说真的是一件很难做到的事情。像许多心理偏差一样，我们淡化对他人的影响力的倾向可能会产生深远的影响。它会阻止我们寻求本可以得到的帮助。它会阻止我们主动与陌生人交朋友。它也可能导致我们屈服于不道德的要求，或者对他人提出不恰当的要求。我问凡妮莎她的研究是如何促使她在自己的生活中做出不同的事情的。它在小事上产生了巨大的差异。
So for example, when I was pregnant, if I needed a seat on the subway or on a train, I would kind of stand there and look around and try to look my most pathetic so that someone would give me their seat, thinking that someone would step up and do it because they were nice, right? But in fact, everyone's all involved in their own stuff. They're not necessarily looking around and paying attention. And maybe they'd be perfectly happy to give up their seat, but they're not going to think of it unless you actually ask. And so I tried to take that into account, so when I was pregnant, I would go up to people and be like, hey, can I sit down? I'd really love to sit. And then of course people are incredibly happy to just pop up and say yes. And what's interesting, of course, is when that happens, you're actually giving people
例如，我怀孕时，如果我在地铁或火车上需要一个座位，我会站在那里环顾四周，尽量让自己看起来最可怜，这样别人就会把座位让给我，以为别人会因为他们善良而站出来，对吧？但事实上，每个人都沉浸在自己的事情中。他们不一定在环顾四周并注意。也许他们非常乐意让出座位，但除非你真的开口，否则他们不会想到这一点。所以我试着把这一点考虑在内，所以当我怀孕时，我会走到人们面前说，嘿，我可以坐下吗？我真的很想坐。然后当然，人们非常乐意直接站起来说“是”。有趣的是，当这种情况发生时，你实际上是在给人们
an opportunity to do something nice. It's not just that you're imposing on them. Presumably some of them are actually happy to say, you know, I was just writing to work and now I actually got to do this nice thing for this other person. I feel this little warm glow. Yeah, absolutely. So a lot of people wonder about the takeaway. So if people agree to help us out of obligation because I feel like they can't say no, then do you really want to ask them for things? But people are really good at justifying their behaviors and ways that make them feel good about themselves. So they may agree to help because I feel like they can't say no, but pretty quickly after that, they're going to be convincing themselves that they helped because they're a really wonderful person.
一个做善事的机会。这不仅仅是你强加于他们。据推测，他们中的一些人实际上很高兴地说，你知道，我刚才在去上班的路上，现在我真的为另一个人做了这件好事。我感到一丝温暖。是的，绝对是。所以很多人想知道结论是什么。如果人们因为觉得无法拒绝而同意帮助我们，那么你真的想向他们索要东西吗？但人们非常擅长以让自己感觉良好的方式为自己的行为辩护。所以他们可能因为觉得无法拒绝而同意帮助，但在此之后很快，他们就会说服自己，他们提供帮助是因为他们是一个非常棒的人。
And so everyone's going to walk away feeling good about the interaction. You got the help that you needed and the other person gets to feel like a good person. Psychologists once conducted a light-hearted version of Stanley Milkrim's obedience study. In the 1970s, they had research assistants tan on the streets of New York City. Their jobs? To look skyward? At nothing. The question the researchers wanted to know was whether innocent passers-by would also stop to look up to see what was going on. They found that when more people were in on the gag, more pedestrian stopped and looked up.
所以每个人都会带着对这次互动的良好感觉离开。你得到了你需要的帮助，而对方则感觉自己是一个好人。心理学家曾经进行过一个轻松版的斯坦利·米尔格拉姆服从研究。在20世纪70年代，他们让研究助理站在纽约市的街道上。他们的工作？仰望天空？什么都没有。研究人员想知道的是，无辜的路人是否也会停下来抬头看发生了什么。他们发现，当更多的人参与到这个恶作剧中时，更多的行人停下来抬头看。
I've seen video of that study many times and always found this scene funny. One to fifteen people just staring off into the sky. Recently, I rewatched it, and this time I did what Vanessa had done. I flipped the script. Instead of seeing the experiment from the point of view of the passers-by and asking myself whether I would be similarly influenced, I looked at the experiment from the point of view of the research assistance. Did they expect so many people to join them in looking at nothing? We've seen throughout this episode how all of us as individuals have great power to shape how others behave. If each of us has this hidden power then
我多次看过那个研究的视频，总是觉得这个场景很有趣。一到十五个人只是盯着天空。最近，我重看了它，这一次我做了凡妮莎所做的事情。我改变了剧本。我没有从路人的角度看待实验并问自己是否会受到类似的影响，而是从研究助理的角度看待实验。他们是否预料到会有这么多人加入他们抬头看什么都没有？我们在这一集中看到，我们每个人作为个体都有巨大的力量来塑造他人的行为。如果我们每个人都有这种隐藏的力量，那么
collectively as groups, as communities, as tribes, we are going to have even more influence. The force we collectively exert can be nearly impossible for any one person to overcome. This can explain good things like the social norms that hold communities together. But it can also lead to terrible things. When we are part of a mob, the effects can be monstrous. This week's show was produced by Thomas Liu and Laura Quarell. It was edited by Tara Boyle and Raina Cohen.
作为一个群体、社区、部落，我们集体将拥有更大的影响力。我们集体施加的力量对于任何一个人来说都可能几乎无法克服。这可以解释好的事情，比如将社区凝聚在一起的社会规范。但它也可能导致可怕的事情。当我们成为暴民的一部分时，后果可能是可怕的。本周的节目由托马斯·刘和劳拉·夸雷尔制作。由塔拉·博伊尔和雷娜·科恩编辑。
We had engineering support from Patrick Boyd. Our team includes Parth Shah, Jenny Schmidt, Kat Shuknecht, and Lushik Waba. Our voice actors for this episode were Jacob Conrad, James Delahousi, and Jared M. Gare. Our unsung hero this week is Juan Yu-Jong. Juan Yu works for NPR's marketing and branding team. Every week she comes up with creative ways to promote NPR shows and podcasts like Hidden
我们得到了帕特里克·博伊德的工程支持。我们的团队包括帕斯·沙阿、珍妮·施密特、凯特·舒克内希特和卢希克·瓦巴。本集的配音演员是雅各布·康拉德、詹姆斯·德拉豪西和贾里德·M·加雷。我们本周的无名英雄是胡安·余钟。胡安·余为NPR的营销和品牌团队工作。每周她都会想出创造性的方法来推广NPR的节目和播客，比如Hidden
Brain. Her careful planning helps us reach a diverse audience, new and old. Thank you Juan Yu. If you enjoyed today's episode, please share it with a friend or neighbor. If they are new to podcasting, please tell them how they can subscribe to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vidantam and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Brain。她的精心策划帮助我们接触到了多元化的新老受众。谢谢你，胡安·余。如果你喜欢今天的节目，请与朋友或邻居分享。如果他们是播客新手，请告诉他们如何订阅Hidden Brain。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。